we had this discussion offline and by
the way I should mention that this is
like late at night it is what time is
it's uh nine o'clock and I uh I only
slept one hour last night because I'm an
idiot and I flew to the wrong location
well here we're like hey let's just book
you a hotel on a flight he's like no I
got it we're like you sure we can just
do it we always do this he's like no I
got it I got it he's gonna have to rub
it in I know and then today I come to
find out he flew to the wrong airport
airport with the uh every city with a
similar name to ours the same name same
name in a different state
and I was like that's why you should let
us book it and so he saw one hour of
sleep and he's literally been dying all
day before this podcast he downed like
two things of coffee we've been going
all day hard uh yeah I've been uh got to
interact with you that I should say that
this gave me an opportunity to I gotta
uh ride from a stranger and it was an
incredible person
that got to interact with him so it's
like there's so many kind people around
here it's just like this kind of
Southern energy and then I got to go to
a diner because I could you know there's
only one hour between me arriving and
having to fly out so I went to a diner
there's a really kind waitress that
called me uh honey so that's a beautiful
moment you know I was so confused you
you tweeted about that and I still was
like like my assistant uh Lex isn't here
yet and I saw your Tweet and I was like
he's here he's like no he's still flying
I was like four like an hour ago he just
tweeted about a nice Diner yeah it was a
diner it was a diner in a different
state and then you had to fly over here
yeah that was and then I called you you
didn't answer I was like I was like
something's not adding up yeah I feel
like it's such an idiot because um
apparently the world uh has cities like
Springfield right like there's like
every single state has a Springfield oh
really but I think so I think that's
whatever that's like a Simpsons joke
right that like it's uh this the city
and and The Simpsons of Springfield and
I think every single state or most of
them have a Springfield and the same is
true for like uh Georgetown I think the
most part I forget what the most popular
one was but there's like a list of these
people get when they run out of ideas
they just keep using if they're your
Achilles heel